okay dokey Chris geo preschool whatever
june from the US um yea marry a player
Queens gambit stay solid maybe I can
play the roccos and no chat place the
Catalan now playing a type of closed
catalogue with the check inserted this
is quite a solid line for black having a
decent reputation
trying for c5 mc5 break against his
Queen down an additional idea here is to
transpose it to a stone wall kind of
setup click here and then f5 let's try
that taking the pawn on c4 is always
risky because it opens up the long
diagonal down 495 moves and so on so I'm
trying for this harassing the bishop so
let's get f5 in and make sure that if
why it's not happening okay improve the
bishop Queenie 7 next
seems he wants to go to F form yeah okay
I wanted to just retreat but there's a
possible 95 coming just very but okay
maybe I can go he five looks very shaky
now okay if he go slightly five I have
to somehow weather the storm okay if he
doesn't do it he plays on like a normal
normal move let's say um yeah so see 5
or is this an untimely opening of the
pollution might be very difficult the
same but he lost a bit of time with her
snide move so maybe this is the right
way to go using this groupon c8 against
em is Queen really okay so let's open up
here Bishop cheeks and then 90 form DC
for also is a possible move Mary this is
also good sorry and c4 is just hanging
yeah tricky business if he goes f3 at
jakes you form yeah he can still takes
you form but I said he'd prolly ain't
Knight c3 oh yeah I just could have
played Knight c3 there okay mmm ah no
it's not not a big issue it's still very
good for him for me I could have chicken
you for maybe okay I'm taking this now
white forfeits due to disconnection yeah
that's also a way to do it yeah I could
have done it one move earlier yeah am I
think 95 was very critical this move I
saw it but I when this happened I really
didn't see what else I mean I cannot
possibly take this is a strategic
disaster on the eve on computer does not
agree it gives 0.2 strangely enough gap
and 95 I was thinking maybe I can play a
5 my development is good but it looks
very shaky the whole thing probably this
is not bad though interesting yeah with
this my development is strong and I
don't know if he can't afford this year
this is a certainty okay for white air
for black 0.5 Bishop no night f4 is the
entrance line
yeah I probably cannot do this yeah just
Knight c3 okay okay I thought he can
take this and maybe play this position
but he doesn't even have a good square
that i have i have this move okay takes
93 m and and disconnected but it just it
just the exchange and end a good
position like this this Queen takes and
I can't even take him he has no
compensation whatsoever okay well thanks
for watching